do in another lifetime movie oh yeah
again a reunion One Tree Hill reunion
yeah I only like a small group of people
and so I'm just gonna continue to
recycle my friendships until I'm
exhausted though well I was gonna say do
you have input or is it the casting
directors that are like let's make no we
didn't even have a casting director on
this one what's so great about lifetime
is that they really walk the walk when
it comes to empowering women and so from
conception through the writing of the
script through the directors you know
they they give women power at every turn
and so given the success of the movie
that Tyler and I did for them like five
six years ago and then the one we did
last year is a One Tree Hill reunion
they've really been supportive of just
like you guys go have fun
make it look good on camera and have a
great time what a dream yeah it really
is and in this one so you have Tyler you
know Tyler's white Megan my sweetheart
yes I love Megan yeah I do too Lee yes
Louie Norris Antoine's in this one words
sol invictus is also in this one Jimmy
yeah Jimmy
how is it when you guys all get together
I mean are you rowdy
hard to get through yeah well no it's
not hard to get through the lines
because everyone's very professional the
second that we stopped to turn around
but we're obsessed with each other and
yeah it's probably exhausting for anyone
that's new to us I love what you said
about life time being a place where
females can really feel empowered and I
feel like you've sort of embody that
role over your career like you've really
come into that is that intentional or
how do you feel like that happened no
I'm just like an angry lady most of the
time I have always wanted to produce
I've always wanted to direct and I've
always wanted to create and so you start
off by being an actor and learning the
ropes and watching and lifetime has been
really wonderful about letting
grow in that position so we're in talks
to direct in 2020 which is really cool
holiday muga yeah what do you bring the
cast together ago I'm gonna run all
sorts of creeps and you got friends with
ya know the key is um you know I know
how I entered into the Christmas world
and it was on a dare from my friends
Paul and Julie Rudd I got an offer for
Christmas Rudd dare J yeah he and his
wife Julie Julie is obsessed with
Christmas movies and she's one of my
very best friends we own the candy store
in Rhinebeck New York together and we
were at dinner and I got an offer and I
was like this is ridiculous there's just
no way I'm gonna do this yeah I'm an
edgy girl nice list
I would expect to put me in an elf
costume Oh clearly yeah yeah someone did
and so they dared me to do it and I
really loved the genre as a mother as
someone who like can only make a three
week time commitment to go do a shoot
you know and the subject matters like
fun and easy and not compromising no
one's asked me to do anything weird yeah
and so I really have found kind of this
feminist niche if you will with the
Christmas movies they're great they're
really great what do you play in this
movie so in this movie it's fun because
I get to play an art teacher I've been
doing a lot of work in the last the last
couple years with my high school back
home in Virginia it's a title on high
school and they don't have funding for
any extracurricular activities and so we
as an alumni group started a group
called Project patriot and we're funding
extracurricular activities at Parkview
high school
sterling Virginia and so this movie
really hit home that's what happens when
you work with your friends it all of a
sudden becomes more than just okay we're
gonna make a movie it's so much more to
work that way
no that's so funny it's so funny because
Paul's talked about directing a
Christmas movie and yeah I mean that's
what we talked about yeah his wife Julie
is written one so it's just a matter of
time before that wrote that out there
watch out I do have to say
congratulations officially a mrs. oh hey
thanks oh yeah the wedding how'd you
keep it a secret by the way I have good
friends you do yeah I have good friends
it was small okay you know it was very
small very intimate
Jeff happened to be in town for New York
Comic Con and why not and that's just
how it yeah he had to do a panel that
morning and then we got married things
are yeah when you do it ten years later
yeah you're not as precious necessarily
about it and it was perfect it was
perfect yeah you had Norman Reedus
officiate no Norman did a reading before
I did a read an officiate Jensen's the
one who Jensen Ackles introduced us so
it was fitting that it was his big idea
in the first place so and you had a lot
of the One Tree Hill peeps there Bethany
Sophia I do think people love your
friendship with both of those women so
much we went through a lot together
yeah and I appreciate them as now that
we're adult women like I really
appreciate what they stand for and what
they fight for and I will fight
alongside them for anything
you guys are real Crusaders in this
industry right yeah we're hyper we're
down to fight we all want to just learn
as much as we can and be of service
yeah do you ever see yourself reuniting
with them oh yeah on a project you had
time for sure that for sure what one
could that happen I don't know give me
some money yeah somebody give me some
money
lifetime reps are here fantastic
lifetime can I have some money yeah no
there absolutely will be opportunities
in the future for us to work together
yeah Sophie and I have birthdays that
are very close together and this year
for our birthdays early let's make this
our year is this the year could you
might write something together and then
star in it and then you can direct it
and
you can cover it and I would be
exclusive it's an Entertainment Tonight
exclusive on the set we're gonna make
this happen
great I just you know people love seeing
you guys Thanks
we were lucky to find each other when we
were so young yeah I know you guys have
said no to a One Tree Hill reboot is it
still the case um yeah I mean everyone
knows what went down on One Tree Hill
now yeah and there's no making any bones
about it and so I'm not gonna line
anybody's pockets that was abusive and
so that is that was the catalyst for us
doing these Christmas reunion movies I
would have missed out on a lie my sister
hadn't tracked that contract I wouldn't
and gotten to know you the chemistry
between the actors is there and now we
get to switch up roles I really want to
do a buddy-cop one with Antoine I think
we would be really effective law
enforcement together and very funny
together as well yeah yeah he's my
sweetheart so yeah I mean I I love
working with my friends and it doesn't
have to be one set story or another we
can continue to expand and create and
have a good time we talked a little bit
about Jeff you guys have been together
for 10 years and when you posted about
the wedding you sort of dispelled all
these rumors like people thought we were
married years ago and how frustrating is
that no it's like you know you say
you're married so the people stop asking
when you're gonna get married because
everybody wants to be involved yeah I
would see about it I had never been
married before and so it was always just
you see your own Wikipedia page and
you're like cool yeah what is the secret
after ten years is there one I think
finding someone you could be your best
and worst with is important yeah you're
gonna change a lot over 10 years 20
years 30 years and so it's a choice you
know you make the choice to say all
right well I like you now I'm gonna
choose to like you at 10 years and I
lucked out because I've met someone
who's capable of a lot of growth and is
very very much a good
partner are the kiddos wanting to follow
in their parents but Gus is uh Gus is a
horror movie director like already wait
really
Gus is nice nice and he has been
directing like stop-motion movies and he
my brother works on Silicon Valley at
HBO and sent Gus like a storyboard book
and like blank storyboard pages and Gus
has filled them out like meticulously I
think for sure we'll be involved in the
industry and like George is a tornado
yeah so how does George
- she's a year - she and she's like
grown up on sets and stuff yeah that's
scary for you knowing what you went
through
no because it's gonna be different yeah
like she's my me - baby when she was
born she came in like fashion like her
teeth came and Fang first yeah and so
she looked like a vampire for a while
and I was like no one's gonna mess with
this person she's terrifying she says no
she said it means it is she talking a
lot yeah she's very chatty but if you
say will you you know give my my kiss
no and I'm good with it are you yeah
she's got boundaries yeah will you let
them watch your holiday movies yeah they
watch the Christmas movies I don't know
they won't watch One Tree Hill I was
never allowed to watch stuff like that
growing up cause everyone so I'll see
some Walking Dead it's great why should
people tune in and watch this holiday
movie besides the epic reunion well I
think people should tune in and watch
lifetime movies in general because in
that genre there hasn't been a lot of
diversity and there hasn't been a lot of
inclusion and life time has been really
wonderful about breaking a lot of those
barriers they're being really
progressive about the storylines that
we're doing in an arm movie in
particular I was clear that I wanted
there to be representation for the LGBT
community
they said yes absolutely of course
whatever you want it's crazy it's almost
2020 and there's the fact that
conversation even needs to happen is
really dumb um it's not a plot point in
the movie it's just a fact of life and
it shouldn't be as it is well yes and
that's not everywhere we're absolutely
so I respect how progressive and
inclusive life time is and I love
working with them for that reason they
are open-minded and aggressive in their
quest to make content that's for
everyone
[Music]